the other thing you mentioned
now i should probably be talking to you
about much more important things but
the other thing you mentioned is skyrim
uh do you play video games what's your
favorite game what's
what would you say is the greatest video
game of all time because i'm a huge fan
of elder scrolls oh
yeah i mean i play a little bit um at
this point
you know a little little less uh finally
moved into a new house so
you're like an adult no no no no i'm
like a better funded 12 year old
um yeah that's
yeah that's entirely that's entirely
accurate better funded 12 year old
but um somewhat better funded 12 year
old not as well funded as i wish but
historically did you play video games oh
yeah i played as a kid i was
you know again i've always liked playing
sports and and liked reading
and i always enjoy video games but my
favorite video game i think i've ever
played was uh
knight city the old republic um it was a
star wars game of a huge star wars fan
until
it become less so so recently disney
um you don't like the i haven't watched
it yet oh my
my delorean oh dog oh i actually like
mandalorian that was that was actually
pretty cool yeah
waving this off yeah yeah i will if i
could cancel one thing i would cancel
disney store i'm gonna edit that part
out okay let's go to the next
but uh this is where if people are
wondering if you're watching this on
youtube
and like the dislike amount is like 80
percent it's because of that comment so
good job good job for making the
internet nothing
now what about uh uh baby yoda
yeah i guess yeah he's like he's little
he's got ears and he uses the force
sometimes and he passes out again no no
qualms of baby yoda yeah
you don't have a heart okay
you